he scored goals at every major Club he
played for but it was at Aston Villa
where de lien Atkinson really made his
name in the 1990s the 48 year old had
been tasered by police in this
cul-de-sac near his father's home in
Telford an investigation by the
independent office for police conduct
found there had also been a period of
restraint and other uses of force mr.
Atkinson went into cardiac arrest in an
ambulance on the way to hospital and
died one police constable has been
charged with the murder of daylian
Atkinson a second officer has been
charged with assault causing actual
bodily harm we're not able to name
either officer because it was argued in
court that identification would infringe
their right to life both officers have
been released on bail
relatives of mr. Atkinson said he'd been
suffering from a weak heart
in a statement their lawyer said Dale
Ian's family welcomes the decision to
put the conduct of police officers
before a jury but regrets that already
more than three years have passed since
daylian died the court heard about mr.
Atkinson's career at Aston Villa the
prosecution said it must consider
whether Birmingham was the appropriate
venue for a trial given what they called
the strong feelings about his death in
some parts of the community
Lisa down Sky News Birmingham